in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Sarah
is with us hi Sarah how are you hey Dave
I'm great how are you
better than I deserve good to have you
what do you live Atlanta cool welcome to
Nashville and you're here to do your
debt-free scratch sure am and how much
have you paid off one hundred and twenty
one thousand dollars I love it and how
long did that take you about six years
and nine months Wow
okay and you're making what kind of
money during that time um well we I
started when I was engaged and my
ex-husband and I were making about
seventy thousand at that time combined
we peaked at about 110 got divorced went
back to about 94 and I took my dream job
and now at 89 Wow very good okay and so
all over the place the story involves a
lot of journey here yeah so what kind of
debt was the one 21 mostly student loans
no no car well my my ex-husband had a
small car loan but it was mostly student
loans okay all right and this was all
you paid it all off or he paid off some
of it or I mean we we paid off eighty
thousand together mm-hmm and then we got
divorced and the remaining 40 was mine
because it was at the end of the debt
snowball mhm
so I paid off the remaining 40 myself
okay Wow
so six years and then let's saw a lot of
starting and stopping I guess yes there
was a lot there are a lot of up and
downs there was a lot of moves I had to
move several times due to natural
disasters or landlords I had a landlord
who wanted his daughter to move into the
house so I had to move like five times
right now cash flow to the wedding cash
flow the divorce cash flowing I think we
bought two used cars during that time
cash flowed so and and how long were you
married um a little over four years okay
I'm sorry for that part of the story my
goodness so what do you tell people
because your story is uh quite the
journey then what do you tell people the
secret to getting out of debt is you
just have to stick with it like just
keep going
there are several times I mean there are
a lot of times when I just kind of
wanted to give up but
I just you just got to keep going and
then one thing especially for me it was
like we started with 121 and it felt so
like so much and then by the time it got
down to 40 when I was when after I got
divorced I was like oh that's nothing
yeah and I'm not gonna worry about it it
just felt like it didn't feel like as
much as it should have felt so I kind of
just got off track because I was like I
got divorced I feel like I owe things to
myself Oh medicated a little pain let
the foot off the gas a little right
there yeah definitely but just keep I
just kept listening to the show and
hearing the debt-free screams and just
realizing you know 40 is a lot it's not
fun to have the payment so I just just
powered through and finished it so when
when did the 40 part start how far back
was that oh gosh I think it was around
summer of 2013 so about two years to do
that okay all right plus you didn't have
to talk anybody into it but you at that
point that's right well you know I'm
gonna give my excellent credit we were
on the same page with money we went to
FPU like three times together just
because we loved it so much so we were
really really good with that I did take
some it takes some convincing at first
but yeah it's it was almost harder for
me alone because I didn't have someone
to keep me accountable as much and like
I said just getting myself gifts and
here and there but I understand very
cool well Sarah thanks for coming by to
do your debt-free scream around did you
proud that you made it through all of
this how's it feel now um well actually
I was really surprised after I made the
last payment I thought it would feel so
great and a relief but I was like really
super anxious about it because I had
heard you say one time that if the
student loan company won't take prepaid
principal that you're better off just
piling up the money and sending them a
huge check so I had like 35,000 am i
checking my savings account and I made
that last payment of like 35,000 and
then I looked at the bank account I was
like oh my god like no money even though
my net worth that it had not changed you
know but so there's a little bit of
anxiety I've had like two paychecks
since then so I'm starting to build
the emergency fund and it's starting to
feel like a relief now it's coming
together good for you
Oh congratulations all right Sara from
Atlanta Georgia a hundred and twenty one
thousand dollars paid off six years and
nine months making eighty nine a year
count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one
very good love it love it love it well
done well done